whoa I'm in the staff guy remember it so
you don't have to looney tunes are
awesome
while everyone compared disney to
classical music Looney Tunes were
definitely jazz some studios had the
animation but not really the writing
other Studios had the writing but not
really the animation Looney Tunes had
both they had memorable characters
hilari slapstick and wonderful routines
they're still remembered just as much as
classic Greek mythology like the stories
of Bugs Bunny could be retold as many
times as Hercules or the stories of
Daffy Duck could be told as many times
as this guy you see even Greek mythology
has nothing on these guys or maybe I
just need to brush up on better sources
but am I
I love the Looney Tunes but something
that's not often talked about are the
Looney Tunes movies yeah they're just
kind of brushed aside is glorified clip
shows which is understandable in some
respects but it's still a lot of great
animators and classic directors taking
another stab at the characters they made
iconic and we take it more high budget
movies down the line - in my opinion
there's no we're talking about so today
we're gonna look at every Looney Tunes
movie that's ever grace the silver
screen the qualifications are they have
to have been released in cinemas and
there has to be some new animation that
was created for the project it can't be
a direct-to-video film and it also can't
be just a compilation nothing else said
let's take a look at the first Looney
Tunes film the Bugs Bunny of Roadrunner
movie directed by the legendary Chuck
Jones in 1978 why focus on Bugs Bunny
and Roadrunner in particular because
those are the ones everyone claimed
Chuck Jones did the best so it makes
sense to have him at the center of it
now keep in mind VHS was not really
around much yet so if you want to see
Looney Tunes he had to just wait for
them to come on TV and even then it was
kind of just random episodes this was
the first time you could see a specific
group of the cartoons all together
specifically the worst of one of the
greatest directors to tie them together
the animated new footage of Bugs Bunny
from his Frank Lloyd Wright style home
introducing each short with a brief
narration he references the animators
have created him a brief history of
chase comedy that only a cartoon
character can make up and even some of
the brief themes of YV short still hold
up it's kind of nice seen bugs more
relaxed in between this
like he's lived this full adventurous
life and now he's just my man missing
about it he levels out though with some
of the greatest cartoons of timing and
energy to ever hit the screen balancing
calm and subdued with wild and insane
perfectly it's definitely worth checking
out especially if you're in charge owns
fan but another great Bugs Bunny
director named Friz Freleng thought his
adventure shouldn't be over they should
keep going so we took over the next
several oniy two news films beginning in
1981 with the looney looney looney bugs
Bunny movie well this was also a
compilation of classic cartoons
it tried to weave more of a narrative
between leaves kind of like an anthology
this time focusing up for his free links
Greatest Hits protect focuses on
Yosemite Sam cartoons he's trying to
bargain his way out of hell with the
devil saying you'll let him go if he has
bugs take his place
guess you'd imagine a mini hating the
rabbits in suits the second act focuses
on a parody of The Untouchables
these mostly focused on shorts with
Rocky and Bugsy their popular gangster
characters bugs always takes down the
final part is an award show known as the
Oswald satirizing the Oscars kind of
like the previous movie this shows the
characters in a more relaxed environment
which of course results of them being
anything but relaxed ending with bugs
and Daffy inevitably duking it out for
who deserves the award more now the
downside some people pointed out with
some of these clip movies is that the
narrative changes the structure of the
joke with the first one bugs introduces
a cartoon untouched but here there's
extra endings and intros that alter the
cartoons original intent a gimmick that
apparently dies hard and Warner Brothers
animation but did this one's credit
sometimes the jokes are made a little
funnier in the original cartoon golden
yeggs it ends with Daffy having to fill
up several cartons with this surprising
new gift of laying golden eggs
in the original it just kind of stops
here but in the movie you actually see
him do it and the reaction is pretty
funny is there anything we can get for
you old chap on top of that we stalled
the originals we can watch and it's nice
to see these characters stories kind of
grouped together particularly with
characters who aren't as big as names as
Rocky and Mugsy the film did so well
that they quickly rust out another one
the very next year with a thousand and
one rabbit tails
this is the first one to have only one
narrative throughout the entire film but
given that they still have to squeeze in
the shorts it's pretty disjointed as
you'd expect bugs and Daffy are now book
salesmen who are trying to compete for
who can sell the most they each go their
separate ways and the rest is all the
wacky adventures slash stock footage
that they come across it jumps around a
lot until bugs enters the palace of
Yosemite Sam and his brandy kid who
wasn't to read stories Earl chopped his
block off well still creative in many
ways it does break a few unspoken rules
first off it cuts off some of the
classic punchlines like in one froggy
evening the entire ending is scrapped
with just him abandoning the green
nuisance leaving arguably the funniest
part of the cartoon as well as kind of
the point of its existence out the part
with the kid also goes on a little too
long and I'm not just saying that
because he looks like a certain is
someone when he was younger that haircut
but very in but there are still some
cool firsts in this movie like not only
was this the first one to have cartoons
from combined directors instead of just
one but it's also the first time Arthur
Q Brian the voice of Elmer Fudd actually
got credit for playing Elmer Fudd no
blank had a contract that for lower pay
he would take credit for voicing all of
the Looney Tunes even if he didn't voice
them all he still did the majority but
it wasn't all of them for time though
the right people finally got the credit
and this was Arthur's first the cartoons
themselves are good but not usually seen
as the classic one so in my mind it's
more fun little distraction than a
compilation of their best work but as
fun little distraction goes it does his
job fine that also did well though
proving that not only are they
profitable but they're fast cheap and
easy to make you only have to animate
half the movie so the next year came
Daffy does fantastic island this was
obviously done at the height of
popularity of the TV show Fantasy Island
which nowadays for many people would
make about as much sense as doing a film
on yeah well luckily you can still
follow a TV we've never seen the
original show Daffy and Speedy Gonzales
are trapped on island but come across a
wishing well that can make their wishes
come true so they use Wow their wishes
to turn the well into a tourist trap to
make tons of money the majority of the
film is just watching different
characters come in make a wish and then
show an already existing short showing
us how the way
it's probably the most rushed out out of
all of them not only in the animation
and the story but half the time it
doesn't even make sense like granny ol
wish to be a nurse so she's suddenly in
a hospital in the city but then she's
back on the island again like the
cartoon just happened it doesn't add up
the only thing that's both new and funny
is that they have this opportunity to
get off the island by simply making a
wish but they've become so consumed to
agree that everything goes wrong and
they end up exactly back where they
started it's a clever idea with enough
funny shorts that it might be worth a
glance but it's nothing really worth
watching out to see man I guess a lot of
people thought the same because it would
take five years to get the final clip
movie out Daffy duck's quack Buster's
yep not inspired by any other films here
at all this was the first one not to be
directed by any of the classic animators
but it was also the first one to show
some newer shorts that were running on
TV once the Dinka quite as much playing
time as some of the other cartoons the
premise is Daffy has inherited a bunch
of money but the ghost of the person who
gave it to him haunts Daffy until he
agrees to use the money for some good
finding out that ghosts can exist he
sets up a team calling themselves
paranormalists at large hoping this will
calm the angry spirit before he makes
all his money disappear the connecting
point of these cartoons is certainly the
more dark and spooky paranormal ones
which again it's nice to see in a
collection in such a creative way there
are a lot of downsides to it though
first of all this was the late 80s and
compilation' films just weren't making
sense anymore especially with everyone
having access to a ton of Looney Tunes
shorts on video some of them even
organized by director and themed second
this was no blanks final appearance as
the Looney Tunes before his death and it
really shows they all sound like they
live their lives inhaling a Marlboro
Factory they can no longer sink the old
material with the new material just tell
me if you can spot simply by the voice
where the new footage stops and the old
footage begins oh and one more thing
anyone that works with me should never
get me riled why not because I'm a
personality
be away out of all of them though this
is probably the strangest of them which
in an odd way I kind of kind of admire
it's still imaginative and pretty out
there anyone that liked watching the
more Halloween related episodes have
them in a nice collection with a few
additional laughs thrown in if you can
get through the obvious syncing problems
and have a soft spot for these kind of
clip movies say it's worth it must be a
whopping 11 years before we ever got any
new films from the Looney Tunes the good
news is they gave us phenomenal
animation without any of the old clips
being used the bad news is a space trip
yeah if you watch one of my earliest
reviews you'll know I'm not exactly the
biggest fan it was based on a series of
Nike commercial starring Michael Jordan
and Bugs Bunny seeing how they were such
a big hit they decide to give them a
movie that pretty much had the flood of
Nikes commercial aliens want a new
attraction for their theme park so they
tried to kidnap the Looney Tunes but
they challenged the aliens to a game of
basketball because why not and they call
upon the help of Michael Jordan to help
them out okay my review goes into more
detail about why this film doesn't work
and why you know it doesn't work too
well looking back years later does
anything stand out as particularly
salvageable well I will give it this it
is such a product of the times that's
actually kind of fascinating this is
when literally a commercial could be a
movie not unlike the Ernest Bills it's
when hand-drawn animation and
live-action were amazingly blended not
unlike Roger Rabbit it's what writers
who could barely write for an all-boy
cast suddenly had to shoehorn in a token
girl whose only characteristic is not
being objectified while she does nothing
but try to be objectified even Bill
Murray who said the scripted
Ghostbusters 3 was never good enough but
said this script was good enough as well
as all of these yeah it is kind of funny
looking back in hindsight years later it
is kind of fun to see these cliches
they're so distinctly 90s
I can't say that makes it good but it
does make it kind of enjoyable in a
he-man Power Rangers Saved by the Bell
got away it's a product of the times
kind of charming and how David is again
good an interesting time capsule which
leads us to our final film in 2003
Looney Tunes back in action directed by
Joe Dante who you could argue already
directed only Tim's film this one tries
less to sell products and stake it back
to his traditional Looney ways with mad
scientist spaceships secret agents ray
guns explosions the whole cabal and by
god it tried the film centers around
bugs and Daffy making cartoons at Warner
Brothers but Daffy goes AWOL resulting
as a security guard played by Brendan
Fraser and the studio executive played
by Jenna Elfman to go after him along
with bugs but the president of the Acme
corporation wants to turn everybody into
monkeys and they have to stop that too
yeah even the movie acknowledges the
plot is purposefully which it
is strangely kind of reassuring it's
good to know this is really just an
excuse for jokes and funny animation and
slapstick the downside is every time it
feels like the animation portions get
going it suddenly feels like it comes to
a halt whenever the live-action portions
are on which is the majority of the
movie it don't care about these people I
don't care how much they try to act like
Looney Tunes or be the straight man or
the love interest or whatever I want to
see the Looney Tunes throughout most of
the film even when you're not on screen
you can see them trying so hard to get
back on camera like even they know they
should be in more of it the best scenes
though are when they go totally animated
there's a space chase with Marvin the
Martian and a phenomenal scene where
they go inside classic works of art and
take on whatever style they're in stuff
like this and some really clever jokes
show it has a better understanding of
Looney Tunes and Space Jam where all
they do is just say some catchphrases
but to space jams credit they knew to
keep them in the animated world that's
where they're allowed to shine Charlie
Chaplin once said about the Looney Tunes
how can we compete these guys don't have
to stop to take a breath and that's what
it feels like even when they do have
legitimately funny performances like
Timothy Dalton or Joan Cusack it always
feels slower when the Looney
have to be in the real world and not the
other way around like in Space Jam there
Michael Jordan is the straight man in
this world of insanity here it's just a
bit of insanity in the real world which
with Looney Tunes isn't nearly as much
fun
Heymann Roger Rabbit kind of made up for
it by having great characters and great
story but in this one the story and
characters admit they're just there to
tell jokes and when half the jokes can't
be animated to their full potential you
can quickly see what the problem would
be but still maybe you're a loony toons
fan like I am there's still a lot of
inventive scenes and good jokes you've
just got us great through a lot of bad
jokes and uninventive scenes to get to
them so what does the future of Looney
Toons movies hold it's hard to say
they've range from being gigantica kids
to gigantic bombs
it's tough taking loads originally meant
to be just 10 minutes shorts and stretch
them out in two hour and a half motion
pictures but the characters are still
timeless have left us with hours of
hilarity and if something does good it
can last this long chances are we're
gonna see a lot more of them in the
future
especially if you can replace Michael
Jordan with LeBron James you can replace
a body pillow with Kristen Wiig maybe
baby I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
so you don't have to maybe coming next
week it's the cinematic version of rocky
and bowling
after years of requests were finally
taking a look at but you can see it now
under vessel's ad free early access just
three dollars a month to see tons of
people's videos early as well as a bunch
of other extra features check it out and
get the early scoop
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing the
children's health fund the children's
health fund delivers high quality health
care to America's most disadvantaged
children this organisation envisions a
future where all children in America get
the care they need to be healthy and
ready to reach their potential in
learning as well as their full potential
in just life in manifesting that vision
children's health fund develops
innovative and comprehensive models
reduces health barriers to learning
addresses the needs of vulnerable
children in times of public health
crisis and advocates for the health and
well-being of kids everywhere if you
look at their website and their YouTube
channel not only will you see all the
celebrities there trying their best to
raise awareness of it but you'll also
hear story after story of all the
wonderful people that work so hard and
dedicate so much to these kids these are
determined strong phenomenal folks who
deserve as much support as possible so
please click on the link below and see
how you can help these people achieve
their goal